hey man it's me kevin smith here with
another scene study
of mall rats this time we're looking at
one of my favorite scenes
uh in the entire movie it's when uh joey
who plays uh oh [ __ ] what was gwen i
always i was gonna say alyssa jones but
she played so many characters in the
stuff i did
uh joey plays gwen uh ts's ex-girlfriend
ts of course played by jeremy london
and jason lee the great jason lee as the
amazing brody bruce
this is a scene where we do burt
reynolds jokes which [ __ ] jason lee
always loved they made him laugh
hysterically uh this is the sequence
where
joey when she auditioned for gwen and it
was a long [ __ ] protracted history
with joey and maul rats like jim jackson
promised her the role of renee
studio wanted somebody [ __ ] bigger
i'd never even met her before and stuff
like that
um eventually like renee of course
became shannon doherty
uh then we went back to joey and be like
do you wanna audition for gwen and she
was like oh my god like it was just a
harrowing experience for her because it
was like i'm in i'm out i'm in amount
so when joey came in to do the gwen
scene
she pulled her underwear on over her
clothes
like she had extra underwear and so she
would like pull her underwear
on over her underwear like while acting
in the scene and i i
like i thought that was brilliant i
thought it was great i was like oh my
god [ __ ] and she's like people do
that
so i was like right on that's going
right in the [ __ ] script so
you know the you always you can't say
that like all the good ideas come from
me
great ideas come from sometimes people
in auditions man and since she was so
good at it i was like
you got the [ __ ] part and thank god
mallrats
was a like five million dollar audition
for chasing amy a five million dollar
casting call i got my cast for chasing
amy
ben affleck joey adams jason lee all
three of them
were in mall rats and all three of them
are wonderful in this scene i don't know
the name
of the amazing actress who's on the
other side of the [ __ ] counter
but it's one of my favorite moments in
anything i've ever done and i can't take
credit for it she
nailed that [ __ ] like i know exactly
how he feels excuse me and goes off
[ __ ] camera
uh i will take credit for the armbit
because that was something that i
always said in my relationships and i
was like i'm gonna put that in the
script and it seems to play
other people seem to understand it too
that's what movies are good for
sometimes you put some [ __ ] in there and
be like anybody else feel this way
and people like yeah yeah and you're
like all right i ain't crazy and [ __ ] so
without further ado ladies and gentlemen
the uh
the the uh uh how would i describe it
what would i call this scene the chain
well it's not even a changing room um
[ __ ]
the oh that ski trip scene
ever slept with somebody uh yeah no i
mean really slept with somebody beside
them not just [ __ ] them on a gaming
table
we uh we slept together one time
remember in high school that a ski trip
that was you yes brody i have slept
beside many people
all right you know when someone lays
with their back to you and you lay
behind them really close and you throw
one arm over them
it's called spooning yeah but you got to
put the other arm somewhere
you can either lay on or just shove it
in between your bodies
the only other option is to stretch it
above your head but sometimes my arm
pops out of socket when i'm sleeping
like that
so i was constantly searching for some
place to keep my arm
while still laying close to her
and what do you mean anne that's like a
metaphor for a whole relationship
i'm all out i'll meet you at the food
court
i know exactly how he feels excuse me
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix and some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with y'all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith